so yes we begin with breaking news
antenna star nova djokovic has lost his
fight against deportation from australia
the federal court announced that
decision just moments ago djokovic had
appealed to the court after a decision
to revoke his visa for a second time and
jokovich's ibiza was first cancelled
after questions about his covet 19
vaccine exemption uh let's cross over
straight away to sarah clark joins us
live from brisbane from where she's
monitoring events and sarah just tell us
more about this decision if you will
well we had five hours of deliberations
and arguments from both sides in the
federal court in melbourne on sunday
this was a special hearing uh before the
full bench and in the last few minutes
uh justice awesome the chief justice
also has announced that he's upholded uh
the decision to deport novak djokovic so
djokovic has now lost his chance to
defend uh the grand slam title to win
his tenth australian open uh we've had
the deliberations or the the argument
being made from his lawyers that uh the
immigration minister alex hawke's
decision uh to deport him that decision
made on friday uh that it was irrational
and illogical uh the government had
argued that the case for uh djokovic
staying in australia he posed a public
health risk and the alex hawk the
immigration minister made the decision
he used his discretionary powers as the
minister uh to revoke his visa simply
stating it was on the public grounds in
the best interest of the australian
community community to leave and he
simply said that
him staying here djokovic staying here
and remaining in australia he would fuel
this anti-vaccination sentiment so this
is a big decision after days and days of
this saga going before the federal court
twice
his visa being revoked twice and finally
a decision before the federal court with
the chief justice uh stating uh the
djokovic must go and this could also
mean and we're yet to hear whether or
not uh they will include this but he
could also be banned from re-entering
australia based on this decision that
could mean uh the djokovic could be 37
years of age before he's able to return
to try and compete again in this
tournament now the judge said due to the
urgency of this case purely on the
grounds it's one day or on the eve of
the australian open and djokovic was set
to play uh tomorrow evening he made this
decision and he will hold off releasing
the grounds for his decision until
potentially tomorrow but certainly a big
news story and we could see djokovic
potentially deported within hours from
australia i was going to say what
actually happens to him now is he he's
literally about to be thrown out of the
country
potentially so the first time his visa
was cancelled the suggestion from the
federal government was that he must be
deported within ours we're yet to find
out if that ruling will be included as
part of the chief justices decision at
the moment the court has just adjourned
again to decide on what the next orders
could be and we're also yet to find out
because it's only just happened in the
last few minutes whether or not what
avenues a djokovic's team has to appeal
this decision on sunday this special
federal court hearing in melbourne so
the as i mentioned the australian open
is tomorrow djokovic was set to play uh
but we're yet to find out if uh what
djokovic's team will do next
all right so leave it there for the
moment thanks very much indeed for that
update sarah clark reporting there from
brisbane in australia